Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
January 22nd,
2018 what's going on?
How are you?
How are Ya?
How's it going?
All right.
Um,
let's just get right down to it.
The New England patriots are going to the Superbowl again.
Super Bowl unfucking believable.
How many times can they win?
Games like that.
It's incredible.
I thought the officiating was great.
It was great.
Fantastic.
I liked how it all washed up.
I really enjoyed that referee laughing his ass off after we scored a touchdown.
That was tremendous.
I love everybody who saw that rough cracking up laughing.
Um,
which you are not supposed to do by the way as a referee.
And that guy will definitely get disciplined because what happens is,
is every mouth breathing more and goes fuck the capes fixed.
He's laughing cause they just,
you know,
like,
which I understand that is the knee jerk reaction.
But think about what you're saying.
All right.
Let's just say for the sake of argument that referee was,
was on the take.
All right.
Which you know,
God knows.
I always said that about the NBA.
And then they caught that fucking guy and everybody said I was nuts.
All right.
Put yourself in that guy's position.
All right,
judge you by his age,
you probably,
I'm going to assume he had a wife and kids.
He's got a mortgage,
she's got a house and he's risking all of that and his freedom
to fix an NFL game.
Put yourself in that position.
Are you going to be laughing when the team scores or are you going to be fucking
stone faced?
Are you really going to be sitting there going,
yeah,
good.
Just like we fucked.
It's sad.
You know?
So I'm hoping the NFL films will come out just to hear what,
what,
uh,
whatever patriots said that made him laugh because he's going to get in trouble
for that because that opened this floodgate.
Everybody was just saying like,
oh,
look at all the piddle teas or soil boo boo boo boo boo boo.
I still don't like to ticky tack pass in a fringe stuff.
Um,
however,
having said all of that,
uh,
you know,
I think the Jaguars defense was a little overrated.
Everybody kept talking about how fucking great their defense was and completely
ignored that the week before they gave up 42 fucking points to the Steelers in
the playoffs.
Okay.
When it counted,
everyone just kept talking about how great their fucking teeth,
but that defense is that the only reason why nobody really fucking brought that
up
okay.
Was because they fucking,
they are often scored 45 points.
Okay.
So I dunno.
I Dunno.
What the fuck did tell you about that?
Great Jaguar defense.
He also played in a week division.
They beat the cults twice.
That's why I don't,
this is,
this is my deal.
Okay.
I'm not saying they don't have uh,
have,
uh,
they actually do have a great defense but they're young and they do dumb things
like take stupid penalties right before the half when the home team whose
favorite is only scored three points,
that fucking helmet to helmet hit by the way.
Stupid fucking penalty.
Big Chunk at yards.
And then you take a fucking bonehead pass interference call on the next play.
Okay.
And you basically give the Patriots a touchdown.
You give them fucking hope.
And then also your great defense gives up two touchdowns in the final fucking
six minutes.
So I don't know what to tell you.
There was a brutal hold call on the final,
uh,
important offensive player of the game.
I will give you that,
but okay,
let's say they call holding there.
We're going to run it the next play.
You guys are going to burn your last time out.
We're going to kick the ball.
You're going to be down on the 10 fucking yard line and you're telling me what
the minute and Change Blake Bortles is going to run the length of the fuck.
I mean,
it could happen,
it could fucking happen,
but I dunno.
I Dunno.
But anyways,
that's why I don't give a shit about,
uh,
you know,
regular season stats,
I mean,
okay,
here's a,
here's a thing.
Pumping up the fucking Jag was defense regularly season.
They'd beat the cults without Andrew Luck.
27 nothing.
They beat the browns.
And only gave up seven fucking points.
They'd beat the cults again,
30 to fucking 10 they beat the Texans.
45 to seven.
These are all fucking teams that you're not going to see in January.
All right.
But if you go through their fucking season,
they played the titans twice a playoff teams.
They lost to him both times,
let up 37 fucking points and had a close game at the end of the year.
They played the rams that were a playoff team.
They lost to them.
Yeah.
The only playoff team that I'm looking here real quick that they beat was the
Pittsburgh Steelers beat him 30 to nine and then they met him in the playoffs
and they let up 42 fucking points.
So
I don't know.
I mean,
how much more advantage could that defense have?
Adelman wasn't in the game are number one receiver.
Our next number one option was rob ground Koski and you're knocked him out,
you know,
on a helmet to helmet hit that if a Patriot did,
it would have been viewed as like the like,
like you killed Christ or something.
MMM.
But whatever.
It was a great game.
Jaguars should have won the game.
I just thought they were too young and didn't know how to win the game.
Didn't know how to put the Patriots away.
And um,
I dunno it Tom Brady's Tom Brady.
Not to mention Tom Brady also had like a,
I dunno what the fuck happened
guy cut his fucking hand.
Okay.
We have almost 41 old quarterback with the,
with the fucking stitches in his throwing hand.
Annulment is out and you knock out Gronk Koski and I don't want to heal up
ground.
Koski wasn't doing shit ground.
Koski does something on every play.
He draws double coverage and you didn't have to fucking deal with that anymore.
So I don't know what the fuck to tell you.
Uh,
I do feel bad for Jaguar fans because you know,
that's a fucking football city that nobody seems to give a shit about.
You know what I mean?
I liked the genetics.
You know what?
I've actually come around and those helmets too.
So it was a great fucking game.
The Patriots are limping into the Superbowl and should be underdogs,
but won't be cause every mouth breathing more on who doesn't know shit about
football.
We'll put money on the Patriots for somehow we will be,
I mean,
the eagles just look like fucking world beaters.
They have an amazing defense.
They have to fucking base.
They only have proles and fucking
Malcolm Blunt.
I mean,
I don't know why the fuck are,
we haven't got rid of him.
Um,
I'm sure there was a reason for it,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I mean the eagles should be favorites,
but they won't be just historically cause it never fucking want it.
And we've won a lot.
So,
um,
so then if we lose,
it's going to be like an unbelievable,
I'm flat.
What does it say about Brady legacy?
Um,
we shall see.
We shall see.
And I feel bad for,
um,
uh,
New England fans that are going to go to that game with the behavior of eagles
fans and all of that shit.
And,
uh,
you know,
I saw some of the footage,
some of this shit was funny,
but like,
I dunno,
Philly fans fancy,
you know what they act like.
Do you remember when you did know how to talk to women?
So you just fucking went out and did crazy shit every weekend hoping that the
women would then hear the story and be like,
oh,
that's the guy I want to go out with
and it's,
don't get it,
man.
I just don't,
you know,
fucking vikings fans.
Oh,
hey,
oh,
are you,
you're doing like the fucking Nice Midwest people you throwing full beers at
them.
I Dunno.
But on the other side it's just like,
you know,
that's what you're going to get.
Why the fuck would you wear your,
your vikings gear to the Goddamn game?
Um,
but that's really getting played out,
showing that type of shit.
And uh,
and they did the classic thing too.
You know,
it's funny with,
with every like NFL city,
they are,
they have like the story,
like whenever there's a game in Boston,
they have to play that stupid fucking departed music.
Um,
shipping up to Boston and I lost me leg and then they're going to show Paul
revere and all this freedom trail shit that nobody gives a fuck about.
Who Lives in Boston?
Why walked by that fucking statue a million times?
I never look at it.
Um,
and I don't eat clam chowder anytime Philly in a major sporting event,
at some point some fucking Douche is going to try to teach you how to order a
Philly cheese steak.
It's like we got it gimme a Wiz.
Wait,
give me one word out.
Don't say Philly cheese steak.
You're in Philly.
You could literally walk up there to any fucking cheese steak place in
Philadelphia and be like,
I would like a cheese steak with onions and peppers and provolone cheese and
you're going to get it because at the end of the day,
they're a fucking business and they need your money.
They always do that.
They show the fucking rocky statue and then they bring up the fact that they
threw some fucking batteries.
It's Santa Claus.
Yeah.
As if that is the only fucking thing that has ever happened in Philadelphia.
Why don't they ever reenact Ben Franklin supplying that fucking stupid kite with
the key on it.
Right.
Why don't they bring up the 83?
Philadelphia 76 is the most underrated fucking championship team of all time.
Who I've said forever that I would put up against the 96 balls.
Okay.
I would take doctor Jay and,
and fucking Andrew.
Tony
Two fucking knocked down a lot of what Jordan and fucking,
uh,
what's his face are going to do.
Scottie Pippin.
And then underneath you got fucking Moses Malone one on one against Luc Longley.
I'm not saying they would have one,
but I'm saying,
you know,
be a hell of a fucking series.
Anyways.
Congratulations to the,
uh,
to the fucking eagles.
What a game.
Good Lord.
They,
that was,
they gave them the,
they gave the vikings.
He,
oh,
right there,
Fred.
I,
but there was a lot of biking fan.
What should that they just fucking lost to the saints after that beat down.
It took them right across the fucking lap.
Spanked if fanny.
Um,
is it weird that,
I mean,
as much as I love the vikings,
I kind of was rooting for the eagles just because,
uh,
I dunno.
Okay.
Case Keenan,
I just can't get past that name.
Case keen him.
It just makes me still feel so fucking old.
Somebody named the kid case.
Yeah,
good.
Just name Robert.
Sorry,
I'm being a cunt.
Um,
so anyways,
if you are a Patriot's fan,
um,
yeah,
just know that,
you know,
it's,
it's going to be a terrible fan experience,
uh,
because nobody does anything about that level of fucking ridiculous behavior.
And I think at this point they get so much fucking hype out of how bad they
behaved.
They like trying to outdo one another.
Like you remember a few years ago there was like some off duty cop went to like
a Philly's game and this guy was swearing and shit behind him and he goes,
hey,
take it easy.
I got my kid here and the guy put his fingers down his throat and threw up on
the guy's kid.
I mean at that point it's just like you just doing that just to do it right.
I Dunno.
So anyways,
so now we're gonna have to sit through fucking too God damn weeks of them
talking about fucking throwing batteries at Santa Claus and showing the fucking
Paul Revere Statue and I'm shipping up to Boston and I lost me leg.
MMM.
I Dunno.
I think the eagles are,
yeah,
an overwhelming favorite.
If people knew what a gamble on football I would think,
but that's not how it works.
Um,
but I think it's definitely,
it's the eagles game to fucking lose.
Um,
I might be crazy,
but that's,
that's definitely what I think.
But,
uh,
all right,
so there you go.
There's,
there's my,
there's my football talk condolences to the fucking Jaguars in Vikings fans.
MMM.
Hey.
You know what I'm actually excited to watch is that thing where they have a some
Thursday on CBS about the NFL players.
Like who's like the most to like basically whatever your hobby is.
They got guys in the NFL playing drums,
guitar,
cooking and Shit.
I actually want to watch that cause I want to see how good the the football
player drummers or how stupid is that,
right?
Oh,
whatever.
He got a thousand fucking channels.
You've got to find something to watch.
Right?
Um,
anyways.
Did you guys see that fucking
okay?
The fuck is that,
that that one year anniversary,
I forgot.
Maybe that lady when Trump got in who was was just screaming.
No.
Okay.
I don't understand that,
that type of protest
to do something like that because I think a lot of people were thinking that,
but to literally do what that woman did,
it makes anybody who doesn't like Trump look like a fucking lunatic.
Okay.
You know,
there's so much just weird shit like that.
Like I saw last night,
the Sag awards had all women presenters.
I just fucking for the fucking life of me who comes up with this shit,
all of it just seems like self preservation to me and none of it seems like
you're actually going to work on the problem.
Like,
that's all the sag awards have to fucking do is just have all female presenters
and be like,
yeah,
see that they're all good people over there.
They get it.
It's a show of solidarity as a show of strength.
I Dunno.
I think it's a pretty weak fucking effort.
You know,
we're going to wear all black Tuxedos.
We're going to where we're going to have all female presenters.
There we go.
We've been vetted.
Okay.
I hate that word,
by the way.
MMM.
Yeah.
That's,
that's the whole fucking thing.
It's just a,
I mean,
who,
who the fuck,
who is pro sexual harassment?
Why would you need to go that much out of your way to do something as silly as
that?
Which in a lot of ways is kind of reverse sexist,
isn't it?
I don't know.
Here's one fucking thing about this.
This is the only business I know.
Bart,
is this business that I'm in.
This business is fucking brutal and a,
it routinely picks people up and slams him against the pavement emotionally,
every fucking day.
Regardless of what's between you,
between your legs.
I Dunno.
All right.
I,
I don't,
uh,
okay.
I don't even know what I'm trying to say here.
I just look at it.
I'm like,
well,
if they just decided they were going to have all male presenters,
that would be considered the most sexist thing ever.
And a,
and then on the other side,
if you want all this fucking,
all these creeps,
okay,
well,
eyelids be specific.
Only the male creeps in Hollywood if you want all of them out.
I don't know that that's the fucking way to do it.
If that's an effective way to do it everywhere,
buddy.
Where's the same colored shirt?
And you have all women presenters.
You know,
I don't have,
I don't have a degree in fighting crime,
whatever that degree is.
Uh,
but I don't think same colored shirts is going to do it.
We have to stop Isis.
Okay.
Everybody wear blue shirts on Tuesday.
He's not wearing a blue shirt.
Does that mean he's in Isis?
MMM,
it that what it is,
Bill.
It's as it's as it's symbolism.
It's a sign of strength though.
Jesus.
All right.
Maybe that is what it is.
I have no fucking idea.
Um,
this,
why,
this is why I watch sports.
I watch fucking sports.
So once again,
the New England patriots,
they're in their 10th fucking Superbowl.
They have a chance to,
when they're six super bowl,
literally what Tom Brady,
Bella check,
and these guys are doing as much as you guys fucking hate him at every fucking
time.
We win a game,
the sub giant Goddamn conspiracy because nobody will give it up that there are
fucking great team.
Uh,
what they've done at this point has transcended the game of football.
All right?
You gotta put them up there with like the fucking,
I would say the Yankees from Dimaggio to uh,
yeah.
Mickey Mantle that run there with the amount of world series that they went to,
the amount that they want.
Yeah.
MMM.
The Canadians back in the day,
the Celtics in the 60s.
I mean,
that's literally what you're watching.
And for them to be doing it now,
you know,
the reason why that never happens anymore is because now there's like 30 fucking
teams
and every,
uh,
basically every sport,
it's just too,
it's too difficult to do.
And somehow they are doing it.
So as much as you hate him,
can you at least give it up on that or are you just going to say,
I dunno,
we're going to start weighing football's again and fucking,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
Um,
all right.
Speaking of the Canadian,
say you guys know up there in Montreal.
Ah,
you watch any Bruins Canadians Games lately?
We fucking,
we beat him three times in the last eight days.
And the only reason why I know that is cause Joe Barton from the uh,
the great puck off podcast told me I've been so goddamn busy.
Um,
I only watched the first period of one of the Games.
I've missed so much Bruins hockey,
this and I know they're playing great and they're on this amazing streak and a
pretty excited that they'd beat the Canadians three times in the last eight
games.
I know I have all the games taped so I'm going to,
I'm going to have to watch them and like one period segments now cause uh,
cause I got the Kiddo at home.
But,
uh,
I haven't said that everybody knows the regular season doesn't mean shit.
Um,
you know,
and Regulus I'm telling you,
regular season stats,
just go back to somebody's schedule and look at what they did against playoff
teams.
And even then,
I think in football it gives you a little bit more of a gauge.
But like,
uh,
in basketball,
baseball and hockey,
it,
I don't think it means shit because on any given night,
any they play so many games,
any team can beat another team.
But a winning in the playoffs and winning four out of seven is it's a whole
different ball game.
So,
um,
I just wish more announcers would do that shit.
You know what I mean?
Look at the division,
like even the light.
Look at the Patriots for how many years we've gotten all these double digit
wins.
The fucking AFC east has been so god damn week,
so many years,
so many years.
Like the jets,
who by the way beat the Jag was in the regular season.
The jets fucking suck.
The dolphins have sucked in the bills of sucked.
So many those years gave Gibson,
you know,
or at least mediocre.
And that has given us five to six wins every fucking year.
Um,
anyway,
all right,
I'm done.
I'm done with,
I'm done with the Goddamn sports.
Let's talk about,
uh,
it was my,
it was my daughter's first birthday,
this,
uh,
this past weekend.
I can't believe it.
She's already won.
She's no longer a baby.
She's a toddler,
which is pretty amazing.
And I gotta be honest with you,
it's a little sad,
you know what I mean?
She's now motoring around the house and uh,
I dunno,
it's already going by way too fast.
And,
uh,
so anyways,
it was her birthday,
right?
So I decided to,
you know,
every year for her birthday,
a dad,
I'm going to make a homemade cake.
And I did it.
And uh,
we had like,
Nia invited all of these people.
Like it's weird,
like all of our friends,
a bunch of our friends I should say,
had kids in like the last year,
like the last three years.
So we had 16 little kids over here plus their parents and a few of them brought
friends.
Like we had like a,
um,
we had,
we had a house party but it was just kids.
It was awesome.
The kids were a,
it was,
it was amazing man.
It just blew my mind cause I was sitting there,
there was like 30 people in my house at least.
And I remember standing there thinking like,
wow,
like literally like a year and a half ago,
this would have been a bunch of guys sitting here smoking cigars on the back
porch,
drinking booze.
And now I've got all these,
these kids running around,
all of this stuff.
And I gotta tell you after watching all the kids,
I'm kind of psyched I had a daughter,
two little girls that are made,
they're like little adults.
They just stay,
sit there if they're emotionally stable,
the little boys that they're,
they're fucking lunatics.
They're running all over the place.
That climb.
I got this,
this found out in my front yard and I know that,
that sounds wild bill.
Wow.
You got a fountain in your front yard.
You know what I would say about our farm to go back and watch that Fred Armisen
sketch on SNL when he does a thing,
marble columns,
when they would talk it about putting marble columns on the front of Split entry
houses.
I hate this fucking phone.
I've never liked it.
It's just a giant,
it's,
it's like a fucking,
it's just a giant place for mosquitoes to Fuckin and give us West Nile virus.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
But they give you though.
Then he'd give,
got to buy these little fucking donuts of poison that you throw in there and
then a bird comes by and drink side of it and then the bird dies.
So I never have any water in there.
So these boys run out there that climbing up on the fucking thing.
I'm having a panic attack that one of them is going to fall down.
You get them off of that,
then they're throwing rocks down to the driveway hitting the cars.
I couldn't get,
you know,
the little kids.
So,
I mean,
I didn't get upset,
but I was just like,
wow man,
this is,
uh,
having a girl is a lot easy on the parenting thing.
I mean,
they sit down,
they're like chill.
They're thinking,
you know,
the boys are just like hilarious.
I Dunno if you turn your back.
One of them's going to be,
I get an idea,
what if I jump through the screen door?
So,
um,
yeah,
I dunno.
Made me feel lucky again.
So everybody gathers around,
um,
to sing happy birthday.
And I got this cake that made and uh,
I'd never made a cake before and I didn't,
I didn't try it out.
I didn't want to test a slice and have a giant slice taken out.
So I was basically,
uh,
going to have 30 people all taste the cake in front of me and I was waiting for
this tastes like shit,
the cake's too dry or whatever.
But,
uh,
fortunately everybody seemed to like the cake and um,
after that,
the whole Party was downhill.
That was,
that was like the big thing.
I was just like,
I just have to get pat.
I gotta get on the other side of the cake here.
People eat the cake and they actually like it.
God knows.
If my wife didn't like it,
she would've let me know,
you know?
Well,
in fact she did try the frosting the night before and she let me know that she
thought it could have been a little more chuck.
It just tastes sweet.
I just wished there was more cocoa in it,
you know what I mean?
And I just went like,
yeah.
And then had like a full on fucking panic attack,
you know?
It's like,
why would you tell me that she,
you know,
I'm stressing about this shit.
I Dunno.
That's what they do.
What,
what,
what would they be doing if they weren't fucking criticizing us?
Okay.
Why can't there be an award show about that?
Would they protest?
The lack of complements a man gets the second he marries a woman.
I don't give a shit if my wife cooked his shoe.
How does it taste bill?
Oh,
it's delicious though.
It can I board that the laces,
it's almost like pasta except their shoelaces.
You know,
put on a fucking brave face
Jimmy Times I've made something.
Okay,
I've made my wife dinner and she's been the first bite she bites into.
She goes,
[inaudible],
[inaudible], [inaudible] [inaudible] and then she runs over and grabs some salt
or something like that.
Or just like if I ever fucking,
a few times I've ever done that,
I did it for,
I think for the first time since I can ever remember.
I did it this year and I,
it was just one of those nights,
it was late night and she was tired and she just went to the fridge and she
usually can look in there and figure something out.
And this time she just didn't and throw it together and it wasn't good.
And she was like,
how was it?
I didn't say anything.
I just kind of gave her a look like,
and then she immediately,
she was just like,
you think it's bad?
And then immediately Heidi be like,
no,
no.
It's good.
Just,
you know,
you've made better,
you know?
And then he'd just
fallen down the fucking whole.
You're like,
why did I,
why was I honest?
She does it to me all the fucking time.
Okay.
I thought this was a little dry.
I did teach would be gigging yet it's like,
oh fuck.
I feel like I'm on the,
uh,
the iron chef.
Whenever I put something on the fucking table.
I mean,
I'm literally talking like oatmeal.
Like if I put too much milk in there,
she'd be like,
it's too soupy.
It's too soupy,
and I want to be like,
you know what?
If it wasn't as hot as it was,
what bill was it?
As hard as it is,
I would literally dump that over your fucking head.
All right.
What do you,
what do you like a food critic?
Yeah.
This is actually making me upset kind of a fucking person.
Another person makes them a meal and all you do is criticize it.
How about you at least go,
hey,
I really appreciated that you took the time out to make me a meal.
That's one of the most kindest,
loving things that one human being can do for another meeting,
a human being.
Having said that,
I like a little bit less milk.
There's no way to criticize it without coming off like a jerk.
I'm just in the future just to let you know,
I like a little less milk,
by the way,
making a homemade cake.
Not that hard.
It's not that hard.
Don't be intimidated.
It's easy up making a pie.
The Pie crust,
that's a fucking art.
Making a cake,
not that fucking hard.
Um,
I made a three layered cake and what's going to happen is,
um,
each layer is going to be a little fucking little.
Uh,
I know I was really hard to try and make them level.
I don't know how to do that yet.
I'm sure there's something I can watch them on youtube.
But when you go to make it,
if you know each layer cake,
you know if one's leaning to the left,
the other lean to the right,
you just spin them around.
You put them together like Legos and know that you're going to have frosting in
the middle.
We can kind of level it out and no one's going to notice my,
my,
my cake had a little lean to it.
Nothing crazy.
Um,
probably the hardest thing is frosting the cake.
I started to watch videos on that,
but it was just,
that was just too full.
It was just too fucking boring.
And there was all this playoff football on.
I wanted to watch that.
So,
um,
I probably could've done a better job at that.
I don't know.
I'll ask my wife,
God knows she'll fucking tell me right.
But enough with me complaining about her complaining.
Right.
I should,
I should be,
I should be secure enough
in my own baking skills.
Um,
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
no,
no.
You did this one wrong.
You know,
I was trying to,
cause I never a lot of shit to talk about,
uh,
this week.
Um,
other than just being completely blown away that my daughter's already a year
old.
I can't believe it.
And,
uh,
I got her up this morning,
you know,
and I just couldn't believe how big she was.
And I was already thinking like she used to be able to fit like her head would
go from my elbow,
not even to the tips of my fingers.
Like I could just hold it just like that.
Now she just,
she's,
she's huge.
What happened?
You know,
there's nothing I can now see why people have a bunch of kids.
Cause you keep wanting to hit reset.
There's nothing better than having a baby around your house.
It's the greatest.
It's like a puppy times a million.
Um,
but what is cool is she starting to talk.
So I'm waiting for these,
uh,
the conversation cause some of the kids,
my God,
they were hilarious.
Um,
there was this little boy,
right?
And he was talking to this,
they wanted to see like outside my house,
like along the side.
So I got all right,
I'll take you over there.
Just be careful.
Cause you know,
there's all these concrete steps and shit.
I don't want somebody's fallen down.
So,
uh,
he points to his side of the house.
He goes,
what?
This and a,
I go,
oh that's the back of the chimney.
And it was a little kid.
He goes,
what's that?
And then the little girl answers and she goes,
that's where Santa Claus comes down and the smoke goes up when you have a fire.
Then I think the little kid like the girl,
and he goes,
he says to me,
he goes,
does she live here?
And I started the answer.
The girl once again answered the question.
She goes,
no.
I live out in the desert and the boy goes in the sand.
She goes,
now what the heck?
Kit was bombing.
I was pulling for him.
I was like,
Oh,
you don't say something funny,
make a lap.
Um,
whatever.
I just liked that he was working on his game at like four years of age.
Um,
which reminded me when I was a little kid.
I liked this girl who lived in my neighborhood.
So I just went over a house,
not even invited.
I just went over her house,
knocked on the door,
take her name was Michelle.
I knocked in the door to mommy and says,
I was like,
yeah,
hey,
it's Michelle Holmes.
She goes,
yeah,
she's sitting there watching TV.
And I go,
okay.
So I went in there and I sat down and watched TV with the her,
her mother,
and I think her younger sibling.
And I never said a word for like an hour.
I just sat there watching t cause I didn't know it all.
I didn't know what to do.
And then I just got up and left.
I always wondered what that woman was thinking.
Like this little redheaded boy came over to visit my,
our,
our daughter today.
Honey.
He came,
he didn't say a word then he left.
I said an odd little fellow.
Um,
anyways.
All right,
let me read a little bit advertising here for this week.
All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Joe.
I remember there was another girl I had a crush on.
There was these two twins when I was in first grade and I had a crush on one of
them.
And uh,
the other one had this giant pen,
which I thought was the coolest thing ever.
Even though it was pink,
it was just a giant pen,
which was amazing in early seventies
like there was no fucking computers and share,
I guess they were wearable computers with gigantic.
So she dropped it on the floor and she didn't realize it.
And I took it and then I started writing with it.
It was funny was the way they had the desk set up.
They had like us in like little groups of four and we faced each other and she
was diagonal to me and I'm writing with this giant pink pen and she's gone.
That's my pen.
And I was like,
no,
it isn't.
It's mine.
So she's like an idiot.
And then she tells the teacher,
okay,
and then she's going to Billy,
is that your pen?
And I was like,
yes.
And then the girl's going,
no,
it was my pet.
I was going,
no,
it is.
And it's my pen.
And then she did teach you just like,
I don't think your mom would buy you a pig pen.
And she took it and gave it back to the girl.
And you know,
as a little kid,
like the embarrassment of that goes away like eight seconds later,
you can't even remember.
Like,
you know,
you don't have like the mental capacity to be like,
did I just really try to pull that off?
Okay.
You know,
why the fuck would I do that?
Right.
So then I remember I went out,
asked and I had to go to the bathroom.
So I went out to the bathroom and her twin sister,
the one I had the crush on,
oh,
this is like the next day I went out to go to the bathroom and her twin sister,
who I had a crush on
k walking out at the same time.
And when she saw me,
she really put her eyebrows down.
She goes,
I heard what you did.
I heard you tried to steal my sister's pen.
And I just looked at,
I think I said,
no I didn't.
And I just walked away.
And that was the end of that romance.
Um,
oh,
there's a lot of sad stories.
All right.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody.
Okay?
Everyone knows dollar shave club ships.
Amazing raises for a few bucks.
What you might not know is that dollar shave club also has products for pretty
much everything else.
You need the bathroom.
By the way.
I was in first grade when that happened.
I should think it was some Weirdo and like the fifth grade stealing pink pens.
All right.
Body Wash,
shampoo,
Hair Gel,
lip balm,
everything for a limited time.
Dollar Shave Club is basically giving away their shit.
Shower shave status set to new members for only $5.
They started a set of features.
They're executive razor and three trials,
size versions of their most popular products that help you stay fresh,
so fresh and so clean.
Uh,
in your first box you will receive their shave butter bodywash in one wipe
challis but wipes,
um,
you will also receive their executive razor which includes their premium,
weighty handle and full cassette of cartridges.
After the first box for placement cartridges are sent for only a few bucks a
month.
This offers excuse exclusively available@dollarshaveclub.com slash bird that's
dollar shave club.com/burr dollar shave club's high quality products.
We'll have you covered from cheeks to butt cheeks.
There is no better time to try the club.
You know what's funny?
The only time I noticed that my Invisalign in at this point is when I go to read
this copy.
I already suck at reading out loud,
but I become this mush mouth jackass.
By the way.
I'm on train number seven of 16.
Wednesday I go to trade number eight and I'll be fucking halfway done all week
from now.
Be Halfway done.
Um,
okay.
Yeah,
I've got to tell you I'm happy that I'm doing it.
They're happy that I'm doing it,
you know,
then all I to do for the rest of my life is at night.
It's throwing a little fucking mouth guard to keep the teeth where they're where
they are.
And I'll have all of these will have nice teeth like Farrah Fawcett,
you know,
I'll fucking white.
You know,
my skin just gets older and older,
you know,
people keep their teeth looking nice and young,
so it looks like led lights coming out of the year.
Old fucking proved up face.
All right.
Movement watches everybody.
MVMT.
Uh,
and it's that time of year when you could say,
I'd like a nice watch for no money.
All right?
And it's that time of year again.
Uh,
you thought gift giving was all over after Christmas,
but Valentine's Day is coming up and you know what that means?
That means that guy has to spend money and the woman does not,
even though it's both of your relationships,
right?
It's both of your relationship,
I should say.
Okay.
I mean,
if we really want to have everything equal,
how about every other year the lady pays for it,
right?
Takes you out for a steak dinner.
Okay.
Blows you in the back of the Uber on the way home.
Just,
you know,
make an effort.
Ladies,
just make an effort by,
but Valentine's Day is coming up,
so you know,
you must find the perfect gift.
You know what I love about the fact that I'm already married is I don't have to
deal with the pressure,
this fucking horse shit anymore.
You know what I mean?
That whole,
where is this relationship going?
Oh,
shut up.
Shut the fuck up.
Talk about how you may have procrastinated in the past or your own experience
with how hard finding the perfect Valentine's Day gift can be.
Okay.
Well,
you know,
you,
who the fuck knows what a woman wants,
right?
Jesus Christ that change.
There's every five seconds and God knows it's going to be expensive.
What if you don't have a lot of money and the woman you went,
so you just sort of banging,
then you're not sure if you're going to marry you,
but you got to get her something nice so she'll keep touching it,
right?
Would it be nice to be goodbye or nice watch,
but not break the bank?
Our friends at movement watches the ones who reveleigh revolutionized the watch
game,
have put together the perfect gift guide to make your life easy.
Whether you're shopping for him or her by,
ah,
yeah,
like a what,
what,
what women,
all they're worried about is what the fuck they're wearing.
Don't decide,
you know,
I really don't like this holiday,
by the way.
Don't go out on the 14th.
Go out on the 15th when prices come back to what they should be.
Uh,
whether you're shopping for him or her,
uh,
want watches,
or their new fashion forward bracelets,
sunglasses,
or any combination in their limited edition.
Gift Box,
M v e n t movement.
Watch movements in house stylists have curated the most overly used fucking word
ever curated.
They're trendy is pieces for gift ideas.
Your special,
someone will love.
Talk about how you expand.
Now what do I have to talk about?
Talk about how you experienced shopping the site,
looking for gifts for others,
movement new watches,
styles for her.
Sunglasses and Bryson.
I haven't gone to the website.
All right,
I'm married.
Okay.
Which means I have to go for something more than this.
High,
more high end than movement.
Fucking watch.
I wish movement watches was around when I was single.
Big All what?
I'd be surfing that fucker website right now.
A movement and their stylists have curated,
once again,
they used the word again and interactive gift guide to make Valentine's shopping
painless.
What?
Somebody should have vetted this copy to make sure he didn't use that word
twice.
She can find the perfect gift for him or her watches,
bracelets and sunglasses,
or any combination of these gifts in a limited edition gift box.
Get 15% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to move and watch
watches.com/ [inaudible] go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr join the movement.
You know what's amazing by the way,
is evidently the government shutdown and everything's still seems to be working.
A legal zoom.
Yeah.
Now that there's new year's madness is over,
it's time to work on your story for 2018 work on your story.
Okay.
Legal Zoom can help you make this year,
this the year you finally get serious about launching and running your own
business.
They can also help you rest a little easier knowing that your family's future is
squared away with the right,
the right estate plan.
I finally did this shit,
by the way.
I finally did this,
so my family's okay.
It's going to be,
they're going to be okay.
You got to do it.
You got to fucking do it.
All right?
As a matter of fact,
legal zoom has been helping people just like you take care of their dreams and
responsibilities to more than 16 years.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they have the resources and ladies,
don't be afraid to do this yourself too.
You know what I mean?
It'd be nice if when you guys kicked the bucket,
we got a little doe,
ray,
me legal zoom is not a law firm and they had the resources to keep you on the
right path,
including advice from their nationwide network of independent attorneys all at
your fingertips,
whether you want to take your business to the next level or take control of your
family's future with an estate planning.
Legal Zoom plugs right into your life without billing you by the hour because
legal zoom,
all pricing is given up front.
Start writing your 2018 story@legalzoom.com now fan for a special savings,
be sure to enter the Promo Code Burr in the referral box at checkout legal zoom
where life meets legal.
That's legalzoom.com and finally,
okay,
lastly,
but not leastly stamps.com here's a new year's resolution.
You can actually keep add stamps.com do your business and save a shit ton of
money this year.
Almost everything you can do at the post office,
you could do right from your desk other than expose yourself in public because
you won't be in public.
He'll be in the privacy around home,
so have your junk out while you do this.
Plus stamps.com is posted.
Just count you can get,
you can't get it to post office,
not to mention it's a fraction of the cost of those super expensive postage
meters.
stamps.com send you a digital scale that automatically calculates the exact
postage you will never overpay or underpay for potions.
Again,
you got the hiccups here.
Create your stamps.com account in minutes online with no equipment to lease and
no longterm commitments.
Key word descriptors.
Okay.
No stamps.com it's convenient.
It's easy,
it's reliable and efficient.
I use stamps.com anytime I send my posters,
you know,
if I'm going to sell my posters up,
at the end of the end of the,
uh,
my shows,
what am I trying to,
when a whore myself out,
I'm going to sell posters at the end of the show.
I use stamps.com to get them there and I'm a moron.
So if I can figure it out.
So can you do not be intimidated by this technology?
And right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale.
Ready for a happier new year.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburgerthatstamps.com enter Burr,
but a,
but a book is a story of a bald headed freckled count.
Alright.
Alright,
let's read some questions here for the week and let's get going.
Billy,
you stupid La Conte.
All right,
here we go.
You never mentioned why exactly you move to La.
I didn't know I was required to.
Why did you move to la?
I just listened to you and Jim Florin cunt.
Okay.
Slash Florentine.
He said,
uh,
and Florentine said he didn't see a difference with comedians in New York City.
I find it hard to imagine that La,
okay.
Oh God,
this guy,
I find it hard to amount.
I'm just going to read exactly what road.
I find it hard to imagine that La,
there are a lot less content and the audience that get offended too easily,
uh,
you then agreed with Jim that maybe it's because you now live there and are used
to it.
But the way you said it didn't seem believable.
So what's the deal?
Yeah.
All right.
Like there wasn't one capitol letter,
no punctuation whatsoever.
A couple of periods maybe.
Um,
I'm not required to tell you why I fucking moved out here,
but I will to eat up some time.
Um,
okay.
I was living in New York.
I was just sick of being there.
It just,
it just gets a point where you know,
you get to be told too old and you're like,
I can't live like an animal anymore.
Which means you're either going to move outside the city or in my business,
you're going to go to la.
And I had nothing going on in my career other than the OPN Anthony show.
But the writing was on the wall with that show where you know,
okay,
those guys,
like they had a bunch of comics on and I was one of them.
Jim Norton got us all in and you know,
there was no money in the budget to pay us as,
but the way that they paid us opie and Anthony Show,
because they are the salt of the fucking earth,
they used to run advertisements of our gigs.
And um,
then our gigs would sell out and it was great.
But then the corporate cons there said that they couldn't do it anymore.
You know,
so then you kind of had to hype your show during the show,
which would get in the way of,
you know,
whatever craziness was going on.
So that's kind of where my career was at.
I was on a radio show and I wasn't getting paid.
I wasn't getting any acting work.
And the only way I was getting paid on the opiate Anthony showed they no longer
let them do
for whatever reason,
which is really shortsighted
on Sirius XM s side because opie and Anthony were this launching pad for standup
careers.
And they will make in like
they,
they made us become like these draws.
MMM.
And then that would then feed back into the show because then these people was
selling all these tickets were like,
hey,
I'm going to be an open anti show.
So it,
you know,
you know what way,
what does it totally fucking work?
It was the perfect fucking relationship for about three years.
And then like what always happens is the money people come in and they fucked
the whole thing up.
So I mean that's not the only reason I was,
I was uh,
leaving.
But that's basically,
that was his,
it's high up as I got in New York.
I was on a radio show not getting paid.
That's it.
That's the best I could do.
I had already done an episode of law and order,
so you know,
and I couldn't get on the soprano's cause that was a bunch of Italians and I
look like fucking idiot Billy red face over here.
So,
uh,
the,
there was like no opportunity left from me and I was going down to the comedy
cellar like every single night and it was like,
it was like groundhog day and I just,
uh,
you and I went out to la and I hated La and I just came out here and I started
to do,
each time I went out I was starting to like it and I was fighting that feeling
and uh,
I dunno,
I just said fuck it.
One day it's like,
you know what,
I wouldn't mind living in an apartment,
paying a ton of money,
but I could actually have like a couch that also wasn't my bed.
I wouldn't mind having a car.
I hadn't.
Then I moved out here.
I had this apartment,
it was still a one bedroom,
but I had front end backstairs the backstairs I did share with my neighbor,
but still,
that was amazing to me.
And I had a garage where I could park my car.
And even though the traffic was fucking horrific,
just the fact that I could live a little more like a human being again,
um,
was appealing.
And then there was a ton of acting work out here that I could potentially get.
And I moved out here and within the first year,
um,
I got on breaking bad.
So that's why I came out here.
But I do have to tell you that the,
that I thought when I came out here that the comedy scene was horrific.
So what I was trying to say on the podcast is when I go back to the New York
now,
it's just like,
it's just,
I think it's just changed,
but because I'm not there every day,
I noticed the change.
Um,
and out here last night,
you know,
I was telling a couple of jokes and there was silent.
So maybe that's what it was.
I don't know why you took it.
So,
uh,
so personally,
but that is a big fucking thing.
The whole east coast west coast thing.
Um,
I do,
however,
I'm one of those weird people that I do love both coasts,
but uh,
you know,
I dunno,
I'm kind of out here right now.
I used to think like I'll always move back,
but now I don't,
I don't know that I will.
Who knows?
I don't fucking know.
I have no idea.
I was kinda thinking about global warming.
Eventually I was going to Ha I was going to have to move back there,
but now it seems like it's going to be all crazy weather.
So the fact that it was hot out here now it's going to be extremely hot.
And the fact that it was cold back there,
now it's going to be extremely fucking cold.
And uh,
I dunno.
I did like 40 some winters.
Becky's okay.
I put my time in.
All right.
I'd rather shovel out of a mud.
Slide 10 this snuff.
So there you go.
Alright.
Alright,
Bill,
my problems with women,
this is funny.
He wrote my problems with woman.
Oh my problems with woman
dear bills burry.
Doughboy oh,
I love that one.
All right.
I'm a huge fan from,
I don't even know how to say this.
Okay.
Furman na Nog.
I don't know.
Ireland,
Ireland.
I'm 17 years old and I've always been a fat cunt.
Well,
that's good,
man.
You're,
you're,
you're looking at yourself.
Honestly.
No,
it's what it,
what can we do about this?
But recently I lost the weight and started getting into the gym.
There you go.
I'm now six one and 200 pounds.
So naturally have started getting more female attention.
All right,
this is all good.
I was never been,
I was never been successful with women,
but now I'm turning this franchise around.
There you go.
Well dude,
you're only 17.
You just getting out of the gate here.
My only problem is I'm a quiet guy and don't not to talk to them.
They seem to just want to talk about bullshit,
our gossip and meaningless crap.
Oh God,
dude,
you can't be this cynical.
It's 17.
The sound like me right now and I'm going to be 50.
Um,
I try and be funny and make them laugh,
which can only get me so far.
I can't maintain a relationship because they open their mouths and I contemplate
suicide.
Jesus,
he sounded like a writer.
You creative or something
or you think too much?
Uh,
I consider myself as straightforward,
no bs kind of guy,
but I'm just a winker.
Uh,
is this a problem with me or them?
I don't hate women.
I just don't get along with them.
If possible.
I would love to hear what Nia has to say.
Oh,
she wouldn't like how you worded all of this.
Uh,
thanks bill.
And Go fuck yourself.
Ps,
if you're getting into soccer,
I suggest you support either Tottenham or Liverpool is they have young,
exciting teams and aren't soulless corporate entities like Chelsea and Man City.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
All right.
Okay.
All Support Liverpool.
Then it's where the Beatles and farm,
right.
I don't know fucking know where.
Anyways.
Um,
all right.
What's your problem?
Uh,
I don't know.
I think you're a little defensive.
I think you're a little insecure,
so you're kind of projecting on them.
I know that that's what I did.
Uh,
so I would say open yourself up a little bit more and,
uh,
you know,
realize how amazing they are.
But women are just like men,
the good one is hard to find.
Good woman,
hard to find.
So you're only 17 too.
And I think also trying to make them laugh is always a good thing.
And,
uh,
what I've learned is a lot of times they just want you to listen and,
they don't want you to try to solve their problems.
So just,
you know,
when they tell a story,
hold both their hands,
it'd be like,
oh my God.
Uh,
I dunno.
Why would you ask me like,
I know anything about women?
Jesus Christ,
they fucking hate me.
My fan base is a fucking sausage fest.
Um,
I got to give you more advice than that.
Uh,
yeah,
dude,
this is a weakness of mine.
Understanding women.
I have no idea.
You just basically a
okay.
I Dunno.
It's like right.
And Charlie Manson being like,
hey,
how do I get along with people a little more,
a little more better?
Um,
he's probably a bad example,
right?
They need just die.
What a fucking life.
Huh?
I just can't imagine spending that much time in jail.
Like he never getting out again.
You're in your thirties,
you're never getting out again.
Okay.
You're not just sitting there like,
really?
You gotta be fucking kidding me.
Um,
fascinating guy.
Yeah,
they didn't all the wrong reasons.
You know,
like you really like,
I literally never come in as far as we know.
Never committed a murder,
but was such a fucking lunatic.
I remember seeing a horror movie.
Okay,
we're all a guy to do.
It was just whisper in somebody's ear or something like that and then they just
fucking would just do whatever the guy said.
Just had that a bit like literally the fucking devil he spent his whole life,
you know?
Just imagine if he ever,
you know,
if he got Micky Dolenz as part of the monkeys.
It's unreal.
Somebody like Hitler's drawings,
so you have to encourage people.
Alright.
Westerns.
Everybody a dear Billy Sundance.
Billy the Sundance.
Okay.
I've been just getting into Western.
I wasn't a huge fan as a kid,
I was more into space and futuristic stuff.
But as a around my mid twenties,
and I'm living more of a loner life,
I'm starting to connect more.
I'm really looking forward to the new Christian Bale movie.
Hostiles Oh,
I can't wait to see that.
I hope I said that correctly because I loved three 10 to Yuma.
I loved the original to my other favorites are tombstone and butch Cassidy.
I was hoping to hear which one your favorites are and get some recommendations
to watch while I'm snowed in for the next four days.
All the best to you and your family.
I would say a the Clint Eastwood's,
the Spaghetti Westerns fistful of dollars.
The good,
the bad and the ugly.
Uh,
he had like a trilogy of those,
um,
the outlaw Josey Wales,
you know,
I hate to say this,
but I've never seen the unforgiven that was right when I started doing stand up
and I just started missing out on shit.
Um,
I like those.
The wild bunch.
MMM.
Let's see,
uh,
the magnificent seven.
Yeah,
the original Westworld.
There's one that combines futurists.
Future,
a rustic shit there.
Um,
Psi Phi and Westerns.
Yule Brenner is incredible in that Yule Brenner one of my favorites of all time
now because he's bald like me,
but I just thought he was the shit.
Um,
I never saw butch Cassidy and the Sundance kid.
Yeah.
I think that I would say that,
that,
that was all of them.
I know never quite into the John Wayne one.
So it's the ones who are too far back in the day.
I like the ones from like the 60s.
I liked those and I liked all the war movies.
Kelly's heroes,
dirty dozen bridge over the river.
Kwai Oh,
that Shit.
Um,
so those are my recommendations.
I would go with the Clint Eastwood,
uh,
Spaghetti Westerns.
All right.
My life's fucked.
My fucked life.
Sorry.
That sounds like a Sitcom,
right?
Oh,
fuck the battery.
Did the battery just die?
All the battery's gonna die.
Oh fuck.
I gotta wrap this up.
All right,
my fuck life.
Hey,
if I don't get through all this,
thank you to everybody for listening.
And,
uh,
once again,
congratulations to the Patriots and the Eagles and congratulations to the
Jaguars and the Vikings on two great seasons though,
right before grades sees us here,
right?
My fuck life,
dear bill and Nia,
I'm 17 and still in high school.
I'm a bit of a,
a bit of a pickle.
What the fuck is wrong with this?
Think it keeps beeping.
I think I'm falling from my best friend.
I realized after we were falling asleep at her house,
she had just taken off from makeup and made a joke like,
sorry,
I look so bad.
But when I looked at her,
I thought she looked so beautiful and cute and her sweatshirt,
that was just a little too big for her.
What does his flashdance however,
she's currently dating a cunt.
Well,
what the fuck are you doing over a house?
All right,
I'm back.
I guess my,
my recorder was almost filled up.
Sorry about that sound.
We had to fucking attitude things together as always,
as always making my life difficult.
Um,
anyways.
Yeah.
So what are you doing over at this person's house?
She's dating somebody else.
Anyway,
she goes,
he's a loser.
No Job's still gets an allowance and expensive car that his mommy bought him,
sits at home all day playing video games,
getting stone and treats people like he's above them.
She knows I hate him.
And I openly mock him,
um,
in front of our friends,
her and even him.
Uh,
like he got her this really generic but expensive looking hard shape necklace.
Um,
when she showed it to everyone,
I looked at him and said,
loudly,
wow,
must've cost your mom quite a big whatever that means.
As you can imagine,
he tries to avoid me.
Yeah,
well you're being a fucking cunt.
Uh,
we share the same friends and they hate him and liked me.
But mind you,
I'm no prize either.
I'm trying to get a job.
Unlike him out Jesus,
you don't even have a fucking job.
And then saving up for a car.
So our choices are two guys who don't have a job and he has a rich mom.
Well,
there you go.
I tend to be nice,
a nice guy,
but can at times piss people off with my jokes and even be a deck with my jokes.
She sound like you're being a dick.
I'm not saying you are,
but you're being addicted.
This guy,
he's at least three inches taller than me.
Enhance summer,
better looking,
I guess he's got this great smile that makes me want to fuck him up for sure.
Well that makes me want to fuck it up for him.
But recently I've started to turn my life around,
quit bare porn and drugs.
My grades are going up,
applying for college,
working out a lot,
but all this in hopes of catching her ride.
Like I said,
she's my best friend and as a boyfriend,
so I really don't know how to handle this.
Any help from you and Neil would be greatly appreciated.
Uh,
yeah dude.
Um,
I would start fishing in a different watering hole.
All right.
You know,
for you to sit there and stand there and be a con to her boyfriend talking about
a boyfriend and you're going over that for over a fucking house.
MMM.
It sounds to me like you're,
you're,
you're less.
Chris Rock says you're in the friend zone.
So what you need,
what you need is you need some time away from her.
All right?
Move on with your fucking life.
Keep working out.
Get you shit going.
And who knows?
You might just meet somebody else and then eventually when she dumps this loser,
she comes around and sees you.
She'll be,
oh my God,
look at you.
You're going to college.
You look gray given working out,
you know,
watch porn.
Who knows?
Maybe it'll happen,
but I can tell you,
it's definitely not going to happen.
If you could just going to be your friend.
They're making snide remarks about her,
her boyfriend.
Come on.
Do you gotta be better than that?
That's just coming off like a,
you know,
you're acting like a fucking,
you're acting like a Douche.
I know.
I don't know how else to put it.
Um,
that's not a strong move.
All right.
Um,
and you should have more going on in your life then the fucker be,
you know,
you should have more self esteem than that.
All right?
Okay.
She wants to date this fucking guy.
Guess what?
It's her loss.
Alright,
so fuck it.
Get on with your life.
Keep working out and work out for yourself.
Go to college for yourself,
do all this shit for yourself.
Feel good about yourself.
You start putting out more of a positive vibe and it's supposed to,
you know,
hanging around her,
shitting on her current boyfriend.
I mean that's just like,
I don't know.
That's not a good look.
Okay.
I believe in you.
All right.
Yeah.
Do what I just said
cause I don't have any professional training.
All right.
Dumping my girlfriend a Billy billboard.
Brow
fucking asshole.
That's another good one.
Recent fatty,
a podcast stand up and all that jazz.
Anyways,
I'm a 24 year old dude and I've been dating and living with my girl for almost
four years now and I finally had enough.
She's a real Downer and talk shit about people including your friends,
like it's an Olympic sport now.
The problem is she lost a job a month ago on account of her shit talking.
It hasn't exactly been going out and looking for a new one because she's anxious
or whatever.
Leaving me to pick up her end of the bills.
She didn't have any savings because she had picked up the habit of going out and
drinking every night.
I honestly wouldn't have a problem,
uh,
just up and leaving.
But the apartment is a stone's throw from the beach and my other roommate and I
really don't want to leave
the fucking decisions people make.
It's right near the beach.
Uh,
the other roommate is my best friend.
Okay.
She's got a lot of books and shit and the bed is hers so wouldn't be a little,
so would be a little difficult to do.
The old put all their stuff in a box trick a deep down.
I do still have love for her.
So the idea of kicking her out hurts my heart,
but I just can't deal with the endless drama and unhappiness.
We'd love to hear what your advice on the podcast and as always go fuck
yourself.
Yeah.
The there,
the relationship has run its course and you need to go your separate ways.
And sometimes when that happens,
you know,
somebody,
yeah,
somebody gets hurt.
All right?
But you're not doing her any favors if you don't want to or to be with you and
you just,
you just wasting her and your time.
So,
uh,
you know,
this is why you don't fucking live with somebody unless you know you're going to
marry him.
I don't,
I don't know.
I don't know if
a boy,
uh,
so what do you do?
Break up with her and then tell him to move out all at the same time?
Or are those two separate conversations?
I just break up with her
and then let her bring up where am I going to live.
And I'd be like,
well,
I don't know.
I mean,
the coastline is pretty long,
so I'm sure there's another beachfront apartment she could be in.
I'm assuming your name's on the lease.
Usually when there's a breakup,
the guy has to leave and leave half his shit.
So it seems like you were in a decent position here.
Uh,
who wants a negative drunk without a job?
I don't think you want,
that doesn't sound like you want it.
Um,
I think the love you have for her was who she used to be or who you thought she
was.
So
neither
those are happening right now.
So it's time for you to tell her to hit the bricks.
Happy new year,
sweetheart.
Beat it.
You can't say it like that.
I just tell her,
look,
we need to talk and sit down.
She could be,
what's the problem?
What's the problem?
Me and you just got to fight through that fucking horrible feeling.
There's nothing worse.
The only worse than a woman crying is when she's about to cry because you still
have hope that she's not going to cry.
So you're on pins and needles.
Once she's crying,
you're like,
fuck,
this sucks.
But you kind of know what's going to happen.
Um,
yeah.
You just got to sit her down and just say,
listen,
I'm not happy.
This isn't working for me anymore and
okay,
we need to break up.
All right.
Just like that.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
And he got to get that out.
You got to get all of that out.
Don't sit there and be like,
oh,
I don't know how to say this,
a Dah,
Dah,
and turn it into a 45 minute thing.
Rip The bandaid odd.
Just rip it off.
We need to talk.
I'm not happy.
We need to break up.
Okay.
You go into the two minute offense.
Get,
don't get out of bounds.
You keep the clock running.
You want this game to be over?
No,
I dunno.
Yeah,
that's what I would do.
That's what I would do.
Just sit down and just say,
all right,
in eight seconds,
this relationship is going to be over.
Okay.
I'm on this side of,
of the eight seconds.
All I do.
How long does it take to say that I'm a timer right now.
All right.
We need to talk.
Yeah,
I'm not happy.
We need to break up.
I just did that and like five seconds
and then she'd go,
well,
what if we blah blah,
blah.
Now I've made the decision we need to break up.
It just,
it's just not working for me.
I don't love you the way I used to love you.
That's it.
What can I say about it?
They get mad.
They can cry,
they can do all that shit.
But the thing is,
as you conveyed it and you're out,
where am I going to live?
I don't know.
We'll figure that out.
I get sets.
The next thing we need to figure out.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well it's,
your life's going to suck after that,
but it's never going to suck more than staying in a fucking relationship.
You don't want to be in.
All right.
And that's one to grow on.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you on Thursday.
All right,
I'm back.
I guess my,
my recorder was almost filled up.
Sorry about that sound.
We had to fucking attitude things together as always,
as always making my life difficult.
Um,
anyways.
Yeah.
So what are you doing over at this person's house?
She's dating somebody else.
Anyway,
she goes,
he's a loser.
No Job's still gets an allowance and expensive car that his mommy bought him.
Sits at home all day playing video games,
getting stone and treats people like he's above them.
She knows I hate him.
And I openly mock him,
um,
in front of our friends,
her and even him,
uh,
like he got are this really generic but expensive looking hard shape necklace.
Um,
when she showed it to everyone,
I looked at him and said loudly,
wow,
must've costs your mom quite a big whatever that means.
As you can imagine,
he tries to avoid me.
Yeah,
well,
you're being a fucking cunt.
Okay.
Uh,
we share the same friends and they hate him and like me,
but mind you,
I'm no prize either.
I'm trying to get a job.
Unlike him out Jesus,
you don't even have a fucking job.
And then saving up for a car.
So our choices are two guys who don't have a job and she has a rich mom.
Well,
there you go.
I tend to be nice,
a nice guy,
but can at times piss people off with my jokes and even be a Dick with my joke.
She sound like you've been a deck.
I'm not saying you are,
but you're being a dick to this guy.
He's at least three inches taller than me and handsomer better looking,
I guess.
He's got this great smile that makes me want to fuck him up for sure.
Well that makes me want to fuck it up for him.
But recently I've started to turn my life around,
quit beer,
porn and drugs.
My grades are going up,
applying for college,
working out a lot,
but all this in hopes of catching her ride.
Like I said,
she's my best friend and as a boyfriend,
so I really don't know how to handle this.
Any help from you or Neil would be greatly appreciated.
Uh,
yeah dude.
Um,
I would start fishing in a different watering hole.
All right.
You know,
for you to sit there and stand there and be a con to her boyfriend talking about
a boyfriend and you're going over that for over a fucking house.
MMM.
It sounds to me like you're,
you're,
you're less,
Chris rock says you're in the friend zone.
So what you need,
what you need is you need some time away from her.
All right?
Move on with your fucking life.
Keep working out.
Get your shit going.
And who knows?
You might just meet somebody else.
And then eventually when she dumps this loser,
she comes around and sees you.
She'll be,
oh my God,
look at you.
You're going to college.
You look,
Greg,
you've been working out,
you know,
watch porn.
Who knows?
Maybe it'll happen,
but I can tell you,
it's definitely not going to happen.
If you could just going to be your friend,
they're making snide remarks about her,
her boyfriend.
Come on.
Do you gotta be better than that?
That's just coming off like a,
you know,
you're acting like a fucking,
you're acting like a Douche.
D and I don't know how else to put it.
Um,
that's not a strong move.
All right?
Um,
and you should have more going on in your life then the fucker be,
you know,
used to have more self esteem than that.
All right?
Okay.
She wants to date this fucking guy.
Guess what?
It's her loss.
All right?
So fuck it.
Get on with your life.
Keep working out and work out for yourself.
Go to college for yourself.
Do all this shit.
Vsl.
Feel good about yourself.
You start putting out more of a positive vibe as opposed to,
you know,
hanging around her shitting on her current boyfriend.
I mean that's just like,
I don't know.
That's not a good look.
Okay.
I believe in you.
All right.
Do what I just said or dope cause I don't have any professional training.
Dumping my girlfriend a Billy billboard brow
I fuckin asshole.
That's another good one.
Recent Fandi a podcast stand up and all that jazz.
Anyways,
I'm a 24 year old dude and I've been dating and living with my girl for almost
four years now and I finally had enough.
She's a real Downer and talk shit about people including your friends.
Like it's an Olympic sport now.
The problem is she lost a job a month ago on account of her shit talking.
It hasn't exactly been going out and looking for a new one because she's anxious
or whatever.
Leaving me to pick up her end of the bills.
She didn't have any savings because she had picked up the habit of going out and
drinking every night.
I honestly wouldn't have a problem,
uh,
just up and leaving.
But the apartment is a stone's throw from the beach and my other roommate and I
really don't want to leave
the fucking decisions people make too.
I needed the beach.
Uh,
the other roommate is my best friend.
Okay.
She's got a lot of books and shit and the bed is hers.
So when be a little,
so would be a little difficult to do.
The old put all her stuff in a box trick.
Uh,
deep down I do still have love for her.
So the idea of kicking her out hurts my heart,
but I just can't deal with the endless drama and unhappiness.
We'd love to hear what your advice on the podcast and as always go fuck
yourself.
Yeah.
The more the relationship has run its course and you need to go your separate
ways.
And sometimes when that happens,
you know,
somebody,
yeah,
somebody gets hurt.
All right?
But you're not doing her any favors if you don't want her to be with you and you
just,
you just wasting her and your time.
So,
uh,
you know,
this is why you don't fucking live with somebody unless you know you're going to
marry him.
I don't,
I don't know.
I don't know if
you,
yeah,
boy.
Uh,
so what do you do?
Break up with her and then tell him to move out all at the same time or are
those two separate conversations?
Okay.
I just break up with her
and then let her bring up where am I going to live.
Okay.
And I'd be like,
well,
I don't know.
I mean the coastline is pretty long,
so I'm sure there's another beach front apartment you can begin.
I'm assuming your name's on the lease.
Usually when there's a breakup,
the guy has to leave and leave half his shit.
So it seems like you were in a decent position here.
Uh,
who wants a negative drunk without a job?
I don't think you want,
that doesn't sound like you want it.
Um,
and I think the love you have for her was who she used to be or who you thought
she was.
So
okay.
That neither of those are happening right now.
So it's time for you to tell her to hit the bricks.
Happy new year,
sweetheart.
Beat it.
You can't say it like that.
Okay.
I just tell her,
look,
we need to talk and sit down.
She could be,
what's the problem?
What's the problem?
Me and you just got to fight through that fucking horrible feeling.
There's nothing worse.
The only worse than a woman crying is when she's about to cry because you still
have hope that she's not going to cry.
So you're on pins and needles.
Once she's crying,
you're like,
fuck,
this sucks.
But you kind of know what's going to happen.
Um,
yeah.
You just got to sit her down and just say,
listen,
um,
I'm not happy.
This isn't working for me anymore and
okay,
we need to break up.
All right?
Just like that.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
And he got to get that out.
You got to get all of that out.
Don't sit there and be like,
well,
I don't know how to say this.
A Dah,
Dah,
and turn it into a 45 minute thing.
Rip The bandaid odd.
Just rip it off.
We need to talk.
I'm not happy.
We need to break up.
Okay.
You're going into the two minute offense.
Get,
don't get out of bounds.
You keep the clock running.
You want this game to be over?
No,
I dunno.
Yeah,
that's what I would do.
That's what I would do.
Just sit down and just say,
all right,
in eight seconds,
this relationship is going to be over.
Okay.
I'm on this side of,
of the eight seconds.
All I do.
How long does it take to say that I'm a timer right now.
All right,
we need to talk.
Okay.
I'm not happy.
We need to break up.
I just did that and like five seconds
and then she goes,
what if we blah,
blah,
blah.
Now I've made the decision we need to break up.
It's just,
it's just not working for me.
I don't love you the way I used to love you.
That's it.
What can I say about,
they get mad.
They can cry.
They can do all that shit,
but the thing is is you conveyed it and you're out.
Where am I going to live?
I don't know.
We'll figure that out.
I guess that's the next thing we need to figure out
and well,
it's your life's going to suck after that,
but it's never going to suck more than staying in a fucking relationship.
You don't want to be in.
All right,
and that's one to grow on.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you on Thursday.